hello there reject nation welcome to part two of
our reaction to the finale for stranger things
four part one if you didn't catch part one that's
up on the channel uh already hopefully hopefully
we weren't done uploaded part two first but part
one should be up here on the channel full length
watch launch we'll be singing with the time
code for stranger things over at our patreon
page for super sexy rejects cover a bunch of
shows over there where at the same tier you
get the options for reaction highlights and watch
along is included please leave a like on this one
and thanks to the boys at prepper for helping
us edit down these highlights let's get to it
damn house most miles traveled
interdimensionally just inhaled
a bunch of that crap stuck in my throat please
don't let that turn into some horrible mutation
this is where chrissy died like
right where is she every death creates a
gate i think there's something in there
that's our boys yes sir right on cue
that is crazy nice
that is so cool i have no idea how
much time is left on this episode
i don't want to think about it
just keep thinking it's that [__] i'm like
no wait no that's right this is the lock
it's so precious
you knew something so small could
cause so much trouble i run it
ah you knew it
what do you think you're going military police
against the wall now you don't
have to be afraid of them
not anymore is he one please tell me
he's one oh my god you might be right
oh snap
that's where 11 learned that ship
like i said we're alike you and i
yeah confirmed damn that's right he said it was
weakening him and i was like why would it weak
111 oh my god she's a clone
brother and sister theories
two zeros two ones one zero two zero
here goes nothing
there we go so just the second you
cross over you'll fall on your head
this is the craziest [__] i've ever seen
in my life and i've seen some crazy [__]
you ain't seen nothing yet everything
all right let's clear the landing pad
oh thank god that was fun oh my god who's
gonna get left behind one of you asshole's
gonna be left behind i could feel it which
one of you doesn't have the core strength
after that man i'm so nervous
that was fun dude do not have a conversation
with him don't do it see on the other side
oh on the other side okay
oh my god i'm so worried about you steve if
they harm one hair on steve's head or chest
what what
oh vac now you cruel bastard
where are you in the in between
no nancy no oh vac now you crawl
back to the pool where barb died yeah
unresolved drama and guilt coming for you
do you remember what you did nancy or have you
already forgotten oh my god when i kill someone
i never forget
steve singing to her ear you
gotta know her favorite song dude
oh did one kill them all and
is she gonna have to kill him
sound design this season's great too
whoa yeah
damn it one you were so badass i
know i wanted to believe in you
wow
there's a reason he had an inhibitor jeffy
kinda like arnold there i know what it's like
to be different
oh right into the lair
eddie don't you like play
guitar or something in here yeah
play some music for her man anything
at this point with a melody will do
what i tell ya wow alice no running it's so big
this is the best thing a journalist could ask for
yeah like you i didn't fit in with the
other children oh my god wow humans
are a unique type of pest
multiplying and poisoning
our world all while enforcing a structure
of their own a deeply unnatural structure
each life a faded lesser copy of the one before
wake up eat work sleep reproduce and die good
point all while performing in a silly terrible
play day after day and i realized i didn't have to
i could restore balance to a
broken world terrified predator
i could reach into others into their minds
they had done things eleven such awful things
i showed them who they really were my god this
is crazy that's why there's always after 11.
but my mother somehow knew and she despised
me for it and so she left me with no choice
no choice but to ask to break free
i woke up from my coma only to find myself
placed in the care of a doctor dr martin brenner
dr brown hair the truth is he
did not just want to study me
he wanted more he wanted to be me when papa
finally realized he could not control me
he tried to recreate me
you were born and i am so glad you were 11.
they're not gone that's crazy twist
man yeah they're still with me
of course they are if you come with me for
the first time in your life you will be free
join me
god it's a whole story it
all it makes sense now yes
i think nina's working
stay in the circle come on get
that extra hour of free time
ouch
oh
oh it's painful
it wasn't supposed to end like this
just the memory you needed
it's crazy her mother saved her yeah
let's have a cue the synth
drums just like that demogorgon
that's a good shot
oh my god
what the hell
damn wow
oh into the upside down
gnarly vector
vector origins
oh my god this is crazy
yep here it comes
comes that collection dante's
inferno zack snyder [__]
yeah oh it's actually over here that
was like is this another fakeout
but not it felt like that was yeah how's the end
and now i don't want to watch a preview
no i'm already committed i'll be there
i'll be there damn i need to watch a preview
pull put them a week apart otherwise we're fine
what a journey yeah
did all that stuff with mike and will yeah
they were instrumental this ceiling you have an
hour and 40 minutes you could include them all
if they weren't in this episode at all i mean
nothing's a complaint necessarily no no i have
no complaints yeah matt that's crazy all right
let's talk about it that was epic okey-dokey
that was a hell of a finale yes sir speaking of
time travel from the time this is uploaded because
we we're shot way in advance what's been uploaded
we are at uh we are 50 48 subscribers away from a
million so i'm assuming we'll be there by the time
this video is up so thank you guys in advance if
one person in every continental united state were
to pledge right or to subscribe right now we would
hit it yeah there's a way to do it and then you
know get alaska in hawaii just for good measure
and i weird they have a really big headache coming
out for some reason and a nosebleed starting right
yeah yeah and um some headaches you're gonna
have a vision you're gonna see some trauma from
the past that you haven't yet resolved and then
you're going to start levitating i've seen it all
um well that was a hell of a an episode god
damn my nail or a midseason that did not feel
like an hour and 40 minutes i know right
it really flew by i flew by really quick
surprisingly it was gripping i thought
i would feel an hour and 40 minutes
it's weird because like i guess it's maybe it's
something to do with the proportions because
it feels like you're still getting just
as much like both character and science
fiction you know high concept action but
i almost wonder if it's just the effect of
it's just a bit expanded on all fronts and so
instead of moving it's like this season has been
very cinematic but instead of moving drastically
differently maybe it's just that they're giving
each scene a bit more time than they normally
would in 42 minutes or something like that i found
myself at one point getting a little frustrated
because i was going why are we taking forever to
build up to 11 massacring these kids we already
know she does it what's taking so long i already
know where it's going just get to it already and
um yeah that then when they had the walkie reveal
with with one on there which was really obvious
i think what wasn't obvious was that he's vecna
that wasn't obvious at all wait a way to go
show that wasn't obvious whatsoever i mean i
don't know it wasn't obvious for me at least i was
always for you good morning children interesting
that's vector yes that's right origins cause
when you gave the speech about one i was like
he's probably one yeah absolutely no i mean
i i always from the start thought that there
was something more to that memory
that eleven has of the massacre i i
of course yeah like there's some reason why she
didn't massacre these kids or she they maybe had
it coming or something but more moreover i was
like i don't think she killed any of these kids
and so i really thought she didn't kill any of
them i thought something else might have like
propelled her well the fun thing to me is that
my initial thought was that was i don't think
she did it i think there's something beyond
that mirror that holds the context but then
what i appreciate is they got me from there then
into a place of limbo where i was like well damn
though these kids are terrible and they all seem
to be like that so maybe it is something where
she's pushed too far like they got me wondering
whether she actually did it or not and then
yeah i thought it was going to be some type of
thematic compliment thing which they were doing so
i don't know if it if it uh undercuts that theme
of you know because it seemed like what they were
doing was like trauma repeating itself and because
she has repressed trauma that she is taking this
out on her life as jane hopper in school and she's
doing what she did when she was younger which was
like kill the bullies yeah the bullies when really
what she's always done is is try to help the
the you know benevolent or the weaker you know
but the [__] brenner's gonna know the truth then
right he's got some videos yeah how many times
has that dude come back from pretty much being
dead i mean he he's i'm saying that like he knew
i don't know what he wanted one to he wanted 11
to remember it this way well yeah i think he needs
it it's it's interesting because there's so much
in both the vector perspective and in this nina
perspective that are about like walking head-on
into some kind of guilt or trauma or or whatever
that might be and so yeah i i i don't know exactly
what the scientific mumbo jumbo is uh but i do
get that it's like yeah he knows what happened
but it's more about her needing to walk through
it to go back and unlock those muscle memories and
find her capabilities once more yeah and uh and
yeah i thought they made a really nice dovetail i
think the other thing too like is that early on i
was thinking okay a lot of the motifs are similar
in that you have the flickering lights and you
have all the kids with their limbs twisted and
their eyes gouged so there must be some kind of
direct connection but i never would have guessed
that that it is one who becomes you know who is
basically launched into and imbued with just the
essence of the upside down that becomes him which
is a really sinister like i'm still processing it
because in this moment you know it's fresh but at
the same time it feels like a really cool book end
because so much rides on 11 and so much uh is
put on her involvement in opening up that gate
and kind of creating this scenario and yeah you
do have this sort of equal opposite in vechna
and an antithesis to her and it makes it a very
sort of personal thing between her and the upside
down which there's always been a quality of oh
yeah the upside down's always been after her for a
reason yeah and i think this is at least right now
like i need some time to chew on it but i think
this is a pretty compelling reason you know and
to go to support the hive mind and just that power
of yeah vecton has never been after 11. i
know and that's something too that i kept
wondering like that was my theory frequently
was like oh maybe he you know was there you know
earlier you know and and tried to prey on her then
and maybe or maybe that's why he's doing building
all the gates because he knows he needs something
stronger to take her down since 11 seems to stop
it all the time also that too yeah possibly for
sure because because yeah it makes me wonder like
yeah why wouldn't he have you know tried to prey
on her but maybe it's just that it's like i can't
prey on her until i am like megazord power and
he's probably i bet collecting the kids and
putting them on his ritual clock totem thing to do
some kind of massive energy surge or absorption or
something you know yeah yeah so because yeah
the mind flier is the one who's ultimately
the top dog yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah one is the
five-star general so yeah not like the origin of
the upside down but i think definitely sort of a
a big slingshot in its sentience and malevolence
it is fascinating what they're
doing here i i think with season
it's not complete yet it doesn't
feel complete right now i mean
i i rewatched the first three seasons a couple
months ago now then immediately swinging into this
and this this definitely feels like it's in a lot
of ways it's feeling like this could be the final
season when i when i know it's not they said they
have one more season after part b is done um but
so far i'd be like this is probably my
second favorite season thus far like i
think cinematic wise it is the best by a long
shot um just like season one story is just
it's just a perfect tail like it's a perfect story
to me it's i'm like that that is just perfect it's
just the right size it's the right size and it's
the and like the the way they flesh out all the
characters you know whereas here you know it's
like i i would i wanna i have to wait and see
what part b is like and then i might declare
this my favorite season b but right now it's
i'm like oh it's already definitely taking the
cake for spot number two yeah it's got aspects
of my favorite season for sure and i'm curious to
see how they stick the season four landing because
it's paced interestingly in the way that
they've released this and i've seen a lot
of people online echoing the sentiment of like
guys go to a weekly model especially if you're
going to do these feature length episodes
so that you can really gather around them
and it's interesting to watch as they've
split it up because this right here and now
doesn't feel like it's complete which is fine
that's what a mid-season finale is supposed to
be and i get why they broke it up here because
you do get such a huge bit of context and a big
revelation and now we get to stew on that but it
is sort of interesting that we have just two more
installations long though they may be and i
wonder how that's going to feel as a wrap-up
and i appreciate them giving us the space but i
i yeah i'm very curious to know how this is going
to feel as a complete season once it's done but at
least right now they're like i said aspects of the
filmmaking and of the themes and of the tone that
are some of my favorites i mean you can look thus
far at the season overall and say yeah i mean you
know like jonathan and mike and will and argyle
like they just kind of trailed off right now we'll
see them again but you know like that's there are
things that are maybe a little less refined here
and there but what is refined is so good like this
this could be my favorite especially as like a fan
of horror and a fan of just when they're able to
balance out more character meat with all that you
see here and i think that also the the plotting
has been pretty satisfying as far as i'm concerned
what was the thing that i was trying to i was
trying to figure out was are they implying that
there is some type of deeper connection genetic
wise with one and 11 is that's that's what i was
trying to figure out because they were saying like
brenner wanted more sort of labeling so are
they some type of are they given powers are they
are they genetically cloned are they what are
they they do refer to them as brothers and sisters
but i thought it was more of like an umbrella
academy thing or or just a title thing
actually more than an umbrella yeah yeah yeah or
or is it just a title thing of you know you have
like they're the ones with powers so
yeah we we call them brothers and sisters
um because you didn't seem attached
to any of them no not at all i mean
he didn't care about his own family either yeah i
mean yeah he's got that sociopathic detachment but
why didn't vegna show nancy everything was just
for us too i think it's just for us just to title
and yeah yes so it's like she i mean it's a good
thing you're showing this but we're going back
to this storyline yeah yeah that's a good question
and that's one there are aspects that i want to go
back and watch again for for the clarity's sake
because yeah i mean i i believe it thematically
because she is the investigator and she's the
one who you know goes and gets in and talks to
creel etc etc so like there are dramatic reasons
i appreciate it and at the time it was happening
i sort of took it as okay she's because she
stumbled upon his uh you know lair right uh
she there yeah yeah yeah the spot yeah yeah
because they said like max max didn't want to uh
she didn't want max to see that spot either or max
implied that yeah so she's back in his like lair
or whatever so i almost wonder if like because
he's a little more like disconcerted when
people show up there if if it was like she's
kind of peering in on or given a channel to
something that he's probably not even aware yet
that she's seeing and maybe that's how he becomes
aware enough to be like oh you're next on my list
for you know trauma camp yeah for recruitment um
but i i would have to go back yeah and and check
because it is convenient to see all that uh but
i mean i still liked that was just a great twist
um so yeah i mean we got that covered and who
is this guy he's the guy i don't i know i've
seen him in other stuff i know he was in like
immortal instruments or whatever and other
things but i most associate doesn't look american
he's british yeah he's the he sings
joanna i feel you he's the youngest sailor
todd yeah oh really i think that's him yeah the
young sailor guy who yeah who's uh in love with
johanna that's that's my biggest association
with you well he seems far from american
i know he's got like he's got the accent down
but at the same time i'm like you you seem like
a british actor is really good at keeping this
out he's got uh he's got bill skarsgard thing
yeah yeah he absolutely does um i i yeah i thought
he was great because he always came across like a
little creepy but the show had me sold that he
was nothing more than some disturbed orderly
yeah exactly after even though you initially
guessed that as most of us probably did
yeah you're probably number one the show
kept going for a while where i was like
no i guess he is just a guy yeah sure why not
just a guy who has a lot of compassion uh yeah
and i think that's a benefit of the longer sort
of storytelling is you can't lead really well yeah
and you can suggest things without being obvious
about it you know it was pretty obvious without
being overly without the kind of obviousness that
comes with being confined to 42 minutes alone
well i think it was cool how they also were able
to visually realize a lot of things um of you know
like what would the with the gates when they go
through the upside down the way they mess with
perspective the physics of it all like i was like
i don't i'm not really wrapping my head around how
this works until they like go through it and i'm
like okay now it makes sense but i was like it
does look fine yeah it does look like it's a very
cathartic thing to watch because you can feel it
yeah and then you see the flip side like how must
have been for will when he was in the upside down
and they advance their technology or communication
skills how to communicate through the lights
i thought was really smart that was very uh
revelatory that brought it back like a lot of
this has felt like it ties into season one more
than the others and uh and the way i mean more
than the others they've all always tied into
season one but the ties back into yeah that's
that's why i mean my hat feels like a final season
because it seems like they're like really going
full circle in this one season but when they when
they get to uh when they are in the upside down
i like i i thought that the flip of it was neat
because before was like pre-teens now it's the
teens even though they are teenagers now the young
ones but before they were pre-teens other teens
going around uh through the upside down and then
watching like eddie and steve and how they have
this weird kind of bond over the fact that they
have dusted they're both justin's big brothers
and they both like want to be that guy yeah i love
them like and i love that they got like little
moments like that hey steve got his uh wish this
episode to finally be paired up with different
people throughout um but yeah the nancy thing is
a little unexpected nancy and jonathan i feel like
after that like there was something so refreshing
in the first couple of seasons about the way that
things play out between steve and nancy and her
getting with jonathan and steve kind of having
to grow up and shed some of his more you know
[__] tendencies like i thought that was all
really interesting and now it it is one aspect
i can see how and i'll wait to see how they pay
it off i could see how that might be sweeping and
lovely for them to be like no it was you all along
but it does feel to me at the moment like they
need something for the personal lives of these
characters it is something we need some type of
room we always need to put nancy in some type of
romance and then steve's always got to be looking
for love and i feel like those are the two main
things we've given those characters beyond steve
always having a new job and nancy trying to be a
reporter and so you know i guess we have to mix
up their romantic tension again and i i don't
know it's one of those things where i'm like
it could happen and there are aspects of them
getting back together that would be cathartic
but i'm not like oh it's gotta be like there's no
other way except for steven nancy it doesn't even
feel like conflicting because you forget about
like oh yeah jonathan hurry yeah jonathan doesn't
even have like a one scene with them talking on
the phone i know yeah they've they've made things
of their you know like distance from each other
but like the show wants you to like not care about
them it's kind of even though in real life they
are a couple they really are charlie hayden and
natalie natalia natalia yeah yeah wow four years
cool good for them yeah i mean good for
them i would love to see some of that coming
to this well i think ever since charlie heeden's
instances i think that's really that's i think
it's the timeline of the way things have worked
out with his character in the show seem to line up
with his legal woes yeah no they definitely do
um i'm rooting for payoff but so am i and uh so
i like that and then of course you know hopper and
russia i thought the way i thought they actually
matched mcmurray an actual badass well and i think
that works mainly because you've seen it go the
classic road trope way so many times of like i'm
a black belt and and they even bother to bring up
like i've never fought a real fight and then it's
a very uh uh uh satisfying subversion and his grip
on russian you know well and also like hopper's
you know um this this mournful state that he's in
and pitiful state more than that it's just
a really disparate state that he's in to the
point where he just feels like cursed and then
hopeful and to have his prayers answered with his
angelic savior yeah i thought was so beautiful
and the buildup to the demogorgon fight because
that you know you knew that was coming and to i
don't even think like the way they they they are
the relationship with enzo and him is good it's
really natural the way they did it um you can see
how they became like actual friends in the end but
uh the the the fight was was so because not only
do they throw it out on the horror in this season
they make it's so much more violent yeah it's so
much more violent upside down [__] around like
it's always the show's always been like pretty
violent but this season this time i'm like this
is like it was really violent yeah gross really
r-rated yeah there's a lot of stuff that is really
like uncomfortable yeah and and the way they
utilize the demogorgon that time around was really
intense and uh it was like the coolest because
normally you fight demogorgons it's like super
dark and shaded and you can't see what the hell
is really going on and there's flickering lights
and here they threw down on the vfx to make this
imposing crazy fight in the in the bright night
sky and the snow and it was so cool like it
was it was a cool one and also like shockingly
violent at times yeah it was like shocking like
there was a couple of moments there that i was
like i can't believe they just did that yeah it
packs that punch because too it's been it's been a
while since we've seen like a straight demogorgon
you know so you got that build up and i love how
they just rung every last ounce of tension out of
that just push into the doorway because you know
what's coming and yet they they're good at making
you like we're sitting there wondering like what's
it gonna be all beefed up and hulked out because
it's been just sitting here feasting on prisoners
all this time but yes there was there was some
one of the earliest pieces of footage they ever
showed of this season was one with hopper and
a flame thrower all right and i'm like oh it's
coming do you remember that image of me standing
in the doorway yeah and it's like he's ready to
flame something that doesn't i'm like where's that
when they're gonna do their thing blood tests
and their thing that in their next season where
they i mean that was the thing when i hear the
run time of of the last episode of this season
which is like two and a half hours or something
it it makes me go like why don't you just divide
it that doesn't make sense make it a crisp
three episodes but then i watch this and i go
i don't know this was like i i wouldn't want to
cut it even though there were a few times where
i thought it ended but yeah but i wouldn't like
i wouldn't have this episode in any other way
yeah we've gotten to a point where i trust as
much as it it does from the outside look a bit
like okay so we're going to wait a month and
then we're going to have these just these two
additional experiences but i trust the way
that they've decided to do this thus far
because aside from yeah that theory of i think it
would actually benefit the show to go week by week
that what they've given us here does feel like a
satisfying chunk to now stew upon as we get ready
for the final count can't go week by week with
with the way they want to control the run time
yeah you can't just one week have a oh well
if you're a week by week on netflix though
oh yeah yeah cause it wouldn't matter for some
reason i was like you can't just put this on a
network television no but the thing is that
we don't have those concerns yeah yeah on
netflix you can mess with that though yeah or
or release some do arcane and release them like
an act at a time or something like i'm glad that
they've split it up to some variety but this is
more than ever and i feel like the previous
seasons of stranger things even have to me
i've been more content with them as a binge as
a one kind of big unit but this was like most of
these are show stop like literally a few maybe one
episode to me right now feels like a transitional
or like a bunch of place setting or whatever uh
and not in a bad way but just like each of these
feels like its own piece i get that it's part
of a bigger story it feels like that but each
one is a piece yeah and so i feel like you could
you know space them out that way but you know
that's just a little thing 100 minutes where is
this where's the 50 minute mark of this episode
what do we got the chess game i'm able to do
a part one part maybe just make it full yeah
yeah just cut down in ten minutes yeah five
minutes of footage from this hour and four
episodes mostly all rainbow room stuff um but
i don't know is there anything we're missing
i don't think so really i mean you know and then
nancy being left there i think that's what i mean
barbara's often is like the forgotten one other
than nancy is the only one who never forgets
and this there's a reason why uh so that's
another thing i feel like oh they're really
the another thing just makes you think they're
time does bring back season one a lot you know
like the second she was in the pool and like
move barbs yeah and with yeah so with barb uh
with having to confront that like that's something
that's always weighed on her and has been a big
motivating factor and that's a meta thing they
know the secret play the music maybe that's when
jonathan comes and he's that's the reason why
he's the one because he would know what song
yes they're gonna call him in california what's
her favorite song dude i mean they're on their
way to the to tina yeah maybe l can beam it
in but i mean even that feels like a little
bit of a meta nod because after season one
i remember people being like why is there
so little mention of what happened to barb
even though they do but yeah like i thought
even that was a nice sort of way of being like
yeah we're bringing everything full circle and
i thought it made that better because it's
like yeah like a lot you are the one who's like
kind of kept her memory alive and yet also this
character has kind of uh uh been done a disservice
by just the circumstances true um yeah i don't
know like we'll see two subscribers away from him
we have to go live right after this uh but yeah
i mean with nancy uh um uh i guess the thing to
circle back one more time is like i i root for
a love story because i feel like each of these
seasons has had that element plugged in and maybe
that's the one thing that's kind of missing here
is everyone's kind of in relationship turmoil and
you get that heart swell when joyce sees hopper
again which was really lovely but i feel like you
know i feel like they're floundering on finding a
love story you can root for whereas i feel like
the previous seasons have had that for somebody
or for a few people at least and so i hope that
maybe the music you know when when that happens
could maybe because again this season is good at
taking whatever i might have been griping about
last time and then addressing it the next time so
uh you know maybe the music and everything will
bring that story into clearer focus but but uh
yeah i don't know it makes sense to have nancy uh
be in the clutches you know for various reasons
now yeah a lot of good ensemble bits too a lot
of good dust and work and [__] out eric is fully
part of the club that's that was refreshing yeah
we'll see i mean we get the next one in a couple
weeks yeah well it's not too far yeah we got to
check back here with jonathan and them and we also
got to check back in with uh yeah somebody else
wasn't in this episode too uh they were the kids
we don't talk anymore we gotta we gotta all right
thank you for watching check back in july
when the show comes back and we come back
and and thank you love you everybody
you